it's time we spill some tea
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
so today we're going to be looking at
some of flat tummy teas most
controversial dye products on the market
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor hellofresh now a lot of people
have asked me about my thoughts on meal
kits and i've always said that i think
they're a really great way to get a
home-cooked family meal on the table
more nights of the week one that i've
tried and enjoyed a lot in the past and
have been leaning on heavily for these
really crazy hectic days is hello fresh
their recipes are really delicious and
super easy to prepare with a lot of 20
minute options vegetarian options and
unique recipes that i really wouldn't
think to make at home
all with simple step-by-step
instructions it takes on average about
41 minutes to even grocery shop which is
sometimes 41 more minutes than i feel
like i even have so this along with the
quick 30 and 20 minute recipes have been
huge huge time savers for me for busy
nights and in terms of packaging and
waste a lot of families find that they
actually cut back on food waste since
they're only using the ingredients that
they need and hello fresh's packaging is
almost entirely made from recyclable or
already recycled content i know so many
of us are just so busy but we still want
to include more fresh home-cooked meals
in our week
so i love that meal kits like hellofresh
make those family meal times more
realistic and less stressful for busy
families so if you want to try them out
yourself go to hellofresh.com
and use my promo code abby abbysharp14
to get 14 free meals including free
shipping and to keep this tight i'm
going to pop out my disclaimer so feel
free to pause or read it in the
description including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey but
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel if you are new and ring that
bell so that you never miss out on a
video but these instafamous products
have become really well known due to
their sensationalized promises of
appetite suppression bloating reduction
their ability to detox and cleanse and
not to mention their ties to reality tv
royalty the kardashians let's be real if
a brand is connected with the
kardashians you know they're gonna be
huge despite having no actual nutrition
qualifications these ladies do hold a
lot of clout but back to these actual
products so the flat tummy company
actually has a large range of products
available for sale on their website so
first up flat tummies weight management
shake this is going to be a doozy oh boy
so this shake is marketed as a meal
replacement which already causes my diet
culture radar to go off
but the website states that one serving
of one of these shakes which is two
scoops of this powder
provides 20 grams of protein 130
calories 22 vitamins and minerals 50
fruits and vegetables and is packed with
something called super citromax which
we'll be discussing in more detail in a
minute there are honestly way too many
ingredients in the shake to list them
all to you it's it's actually quite
intense
i'm trying to be a little less intense
but you can take a look and pause this
video if you want the full scoop i am
mainly interested in zoning in on some
of the unique proprietary ingredients in
this powder
starting with the supposed star of the
show
super citromax so super citromax is a
garcinia cambogia extract that contains
hydroxycitric acid also known as hca
super citromax has been popularized in
recent years as a weight loss supplement
and it's particularly marketed on flat
tummy's website as being three times
more effective than diet and exercise
alone because it apparently blocks the
enzyme that the body uses to create
fat so one study suggested that taking
over 1600 milligrams of garcinia
cambogia extract containing a thousand
milligrams of hca every day helped to
reduce visceral fat and obese subjects
during a 12-week trial program while
other studies suggest that it may act as
an appetite suppressant due to hca's
ability to increase serotonin in the
brain other studies however have
observed no difference between groups
taking hca supplements for weight loss
and placebo groups so i would say that
the results here are somewhat mixed
there are also some controversial
results in terms of its efficacy and
safety as an anti-obesity dietary
supplement not to mention the fact that
we have no clue what happens after an
individual stops taking the supplement
my educated professional guess though is
that any small impact on weight it does
potentially have
will be quickly reversed when the
supplement is stopped but again we don't
have research either way moving on to
the other proprietary ingredients
including bev grad extra smooth which is
a form of milled flax seed and pepsin ag
which is marketed as being a blend of
proteolytic enzymes designed to support
protein digestion and bioavailability
finally there's go luo which is just a
fancy monk fruit extract sweetener now
the remainder of the ingredients in the
shake include pea and brown rice protein
powders various flavorings a probiotic
blend assorted fruits and vegetable
extracts and powders and inulin which is
a prebiotic fiber now in an effort to be
concise i'm not going to go into too
much detail on these ingredients
mostly because they're relatively benign
and common in meal replacement shakes
but i do want to quickly mention the
fiber here i want to reiterate that
inulin is high in fodmaps and as many of
you may already know fog maps are chains
of carbohydrates that are poorly
digested in the small intestine by those
with ibs and they can cause symptoms
like gas and digestive discomfort when
consumed in excess so stomach upset in
relation to inulin consumption is
reported at higher doses of around eight
milligrams per day but people are also
just known to be sensitive at small
amounts as well so for a powder designed
to make your waist smaller this might
not go so well for some
so now that we've examined all that we
need to know about the plethora of
ingredients in this weight management
shake i'm going to share my overall
thoughts on this product first of all
when you're looking at a long list of
these seemingly healthy ingredients and
also more active ingredients with no
transparency on how much of each is
inside it's hard for me to have any
faith that you're getting
like a meaningful dose like i always say
a brussels sprout could be dehydrated
turned into a powder and then blown
through an hvac system from one room
into the production room for this
supplement and you could say that it
contains brussels sprouts i mean that
probably wouldn't qualify but you get
what i'm saying i do not know how much
supercitramax is in this and if it's
even enough to make any kind of
difference to your weight loss
trajectory if this supplement does help
with weight management it's more
probable that it has less to do with the
fat burners in it and more to do with
the fact that the main ingredient is
protein and protein has been shown to
help promote satiety it's also marketed
as a meal replacement so
if you're eating only 130 calories for a
meal yeah like i can see how you might
lose weight do i think that's a
responsible recommendation absolutely
not not even for weight loss but if you
like the flavor in this protein powder
fine use it but i would really recommend
making it into a balanced meal or snack
by pairing it with a source of fiber
rich carbs and fat for a nice balanced
and satiating combo you know the hunger
crushing combo all right moving on now
when i think of a lollipop i think of
the treat that you get at the doctor's
office after you get a painful shot and
you want to feel better but let's just
say
this one's not going to brighten your
day let's finish with the flat tummy
lollipops now if you've made it until
now i'm sure you can unfortunately take
a guess at the general claims for this
product as well these lollipops are
marketed as an appetite suppressant
designed to control hunger between meals
and they come in three fun flavors berry
watermelon and grape the fact that these
are marketed like candy a child would
eat definitely has me concerned but once
again let's break down the ingredients
now the ingredients for all the flavors
include some version of cane sugar brown
rice syrup beet juice saturial saffron
extract and natural flavor so
yeah this weight loss product is
essentially just sugar and like a little
reduced down vegetable juice as it
contains seven grams of added sugar and
honestly not much else however the real
selling point of these lollies is an
extract called saturial now satarial is
an extract of the saffron plant that has
become popularized for its supposed
appetite suppressant and weight
controlled effects so one study
involving healthy mildly overweight
women showed that saturated consumption
produced a reduction in snacking and
created a satiating effect that
contributed to weight loss the group
consuming saturial reported more weight
loss compared to the placebo group
despite the fact that there was no
caloric restriction involved in the
study however it's also advised that
saterial is used as a supplementary
weight loss method in combination with
an appropriate diet as opposed to
relying solely on this extract to lose
weight alone similar to the research on
hydroxycitric acid that we discussed
before other research claims that
saturial improves levels of serotonin
which is believed to increase satiety
and decrease appetite all that said the
studies on these supplements typically
have really small sample sizes and zero
follow-up so we definitely need more
research to understand if and how these
supplements impact the masses
long-term i understand that some people
enjoy the feeling of chewing or eating
things even when they're not hungry and
what i'm about to say is not negating
that desire we call that mouth hunger
and it's totally normal and healthy to
honor that from time to time without any
guilt or shame however i do believe that
there are ways to go about satisfying
that desire to like put something in
your mouth
that doesn't include appetite
suppressing supplements this lollipop is
essentially just sugar and offers
nothing nutritionally beneficial and we
aren't even told how much satoriel is in
the product like it's the second to last
ingredient in the ingredient list so
it's very likely that this is not a
clinical dose and the calories in this
product would cancel out any kind of
appetite suppressive benefits it's kind
of like how people say coconut oil is
fat burning so they eat a whole
tablespoon of the stuff it's very
unlikely that any fat burning properties
would outweigh the calories in a
tablespoon of coconut oil and the same
goes for these lollipops now before i
sign off i really want to talk about the
safety and regulation of these types of
products in addition to the fact that
flat tummy products are not fda approved
i also could find no information on the
website indicating that any of these
products were third party tested there
are also multiple warnings from
reputable sources advising against the
purchase and consumption of products of
this nature not only does the national
eating disorder association warn against
the use of laxatives to induce weight
loss but the fda itself has come out
with an article discussing the
importance of being weary of products
that promote miracle weight loss the fda
states that dietary supplements don't
need fda approval prior to marketing
their products and that it's actually
the company's responsibility to ensure
that its products are safe and that any
claims made about their products are
true the fda also goes further to
provide consumers with warning signs to
look out for on an illegitimate product
i'm going to list these warning signs
along with any proof of them in the flat
tummy marketing that i could find on
their website the first one is promises
of a quick fix statements of this nature
are scattered throughout the flat tummy
website with examples such as our two or
four week cleanse is specifically
designed to help you kick that bloated
sluggish and blah feeling blah blah blah
blah excuse me while i have a
visceral reaction to the word cleanse
their second warning is if the product
is marketed as an herbal alternative to
fda approved drugs or that it has
similar effects to a prescription drug
while there's no explicit promises of
this nature on the flat tummy website
because that would be
that would be bad
it is important to note the comparison
of certain weight loss agents used by
flat tummy products such as hca and
satarial to serotonin altering drugs
like prescription ssris now their third
warning is the use of words guaranteed
or breakthrough
now i couldn't find those specific words
on their website thank goodness but the
website does use words like designed
almost in place of guaranteed in their
marketing for instance our female
fitness app is packed with customized
workouts and meal plans designed to get
you results in 30 days or flat tummy tea
is designed to boost energy speed
metabolism and reduce bloat so we're not
seeing cautious qualifiers like may or
help you boost energy or satisfy
cravings and
i don't know that would probably be
useful to include
lastly the fda provides consumers with
general advice when looking at any
supplement or weight loss scheme so they
suggest you first check with a
healthcare professional or registered
dietitian about any nutrients you need
in addition to your regular diet
second ask yourself if what they're
selling is too good to be true
third is to be cautious if the claims on
this product seem exaggerated or
unrealistic
fourth is to watch out for extreme
claims like quick and effective or
totally safe
and lastly
be skeptical about anecdotal information
from personal testimonials about
incredible benefits or results from
using a product i am seeing red flags
and blazing sirens
all over the place here folks
so if there is one thing i want you to
take away from today's video
it's to be a critical consumer of a lot
of these nutrition supplements that you
see on the internet i have a whole video
on the world of nutrition supplements
that you can check out right here if you
need a little bit of a refresher on what
to look for
but when in doubt speak to a healthcare
provider about the best products for you
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on any other media promoted
products like this that you want to see
me review also make sure that you're
following me on abby's kitchen on
instagram and on tiktok to slide into my
dms with whatever regrettable
merchandise you come across on your feed
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye